It's twitches too spelled with two O's because
Clever? If you saw my review of the first film you know that I thought it was actually kind of well done
Ehh, for what it is
It was a good family fantasy that has some good laughs, some legitimately good drama, and some magical elements. The sequel is pretty much the same.
And not in the bad way like everything is on repeat. They do throw in a lot of new stuff. Heck,
They actually take out a lot of the annoying things from the first one like they very rarely say "Go Twitches!" or do any catchphrases
In fact, I can only think of two at the end where they do that stupid little dance
And then they both go "loser". Oh, that's painful
The rest of the film is once again kind of cheesy
But kind of interesting too. Our Twitches, played again by the Mowry
Sisters, find that being friends is one thing, but being sisters living together is something different
They're snipping at each other more, having disagreements, and not always getting along. But at the end of the day,
They're still sisters and they still connect
But that comes to a bit of a head when their mother (the real mother)
Reveals that another evil force is slowly slipping into their Kingdom
And they need their magic to stop it particularly during an eclipse
It seems that someone or something in the shadow world is trying to infiltrate their real world
Their magic can get rid of it for good
But there's one problem
While most of the people think it's Thanos, the villain from the first film, one of the sisters thinks it's her father
And because we don't see things from the point of view of the shadowy monster it very well could be
This creates a rift between the sisters as well as the rest of the family
Including their bickering protectors, who have now decided to get married. All throughout the film magical clues,
Backstories, shadow sneaking around... all indicate that something is up
But we don't quite know what.
Is it the villain? Is it the father? Even if it is the father look at this portrait of him. Maybe he's a bad guy
too. After all, they were related. The pacing and atmosphere in this movie is still reasonably well done. So many times
You'll just see a shadow
Sneaking in the background you have no idea, is this for good or for evil? And this creates a nice family dynamic among our heroes
In fact, there's even more than that. They find out that not everybody can use magic. In fact, it's practically outlawed
While the mother sees this as a necessity one of the sisters doesn't. And both sides have very legitimate points
It's not something like Little Mermaid 3 where All music is outlawed, and that's obviously bad. Here,
it actually kind of makes sense the choices that people make and the arguments they have for their side. Again,
I feel like that strangely the strength of these movies is that there actually is kind of a family connection
Disagreements don't always mean one is obviously right and one is obviously wrong. But on top of that,
There's a ton of other things that Disney Channel viewers would like. You get to see 'em go on dates, you find out one might
Be a prince, but that turns out he's just wearing a butler's outfit because he works in the kitchen
There's a boyfriend who used to date one of the sisters and now he's dating the other one
But this shadow suddenly possesses him, maybe it seems to be following him
There's all sorts of nice little touches going on. The effects are still pretty bad
But they're at least a little better than the last one. They at least try to go more
cinematic with them. Sometimes, they work, other times they're pretty awkward
but thankfully a lot of it is shot more cinematically, so you're more looking at the nice sets and
Cinematography than you are how bad the effects are. Yeah, for the most part. Again, they can be really awkward
It's funny because I just had to watch Return to Halloweentown where a lot of it obviously steals from Harry Potter
Here, this one steals from Harry Potter, too
But it also kind of steals from Lord of the Rings with shadowy
figures and even a ring and a dark presence trying to take human form
And...yeah on the one hand I could shout "Rip off!"
It does seem to come back to its own thing just enough. And the elements it does borrow from Harry Potter and Lord of the Rings
seem to be good elements that they're borrowing from
Like there's a backstory about how the mother and father met. The father wanted to get the mother a gift
And so she asked for a star. And that's exactly what he got her; a star that can fit in her pocket.
That seems Harry Potter-esque
But it's just different enough to let it pass. That dark presence
you always feel watching you and always seems to be around very much feels like Sauron from Lord of the Rings. But again,
They add that you don't know if it's evil and you don't know what it can do
It's almost like it's similar ideas, but the changes
They make are just enough to make it so it's not really distracting and you're still invested in the story
Add some good one-liners and even some good dramatic moments
and yeah, you get a sequel, about as good as the first one. It still has hammered-in moments and schmaltzy moments, but again
I think that's kind of expected for a Disney Channel movie. When it wants to get a small laugh out of you, it works and
When it wants to get a little emotion out of you it works, then too - I'm actually kinda surprised
I like these movies as much as I did. I doubt I'll play it again
but was glad I sat down and watched them once. It felt like there was a lot more to it than just
Sister Sister if they were witches. It has its own universe it has its own identity
And it has more than enough to keep kids entertained. I know it's weird, but as these Disney Channel movies
Go, these films are surprisingly pretty decent